[Music]
it's the most
high-risk high-reward weapon in the
whole of counter-strike
it has the highest skill cap and the
widest margin for both success
and failure it's gone from accessible
and overpowered
to useless and underutilized
and in that time it's inspired both
adoration
and anger this is the story of the one
weapon in cs go that not
everyone should wield the weapon that
can make or break
any round the story of the deagle
you can buy it just know you better hit
your shots third but it's not happening
to speak there's an eagles here
oh my gosh what is that from cold
flashed off
limited vision limited weapons doesn't
even matter too
great oh the fourth as well how sick is
this round for him and he's looking for
the ace
the first case but blamey is his
kryptonite against three
very very quickly oh my god
as well nico is on fire
[Music]
the deagle isn't just a chrome hand
cannon synonymous with ballsy plays
it's a staple of both the culture and
the competitive infrastructure of
counter-strike
but to understand how it got there we
need to kick things back a bit
you know the imi desert eagle is an all
or nothing game changer
a wager that only makes sense if you've
got great aim
limited funds and a shitload of
confidence
but it wasn't always like that back in
the day when 1.6 and source were king
the so-called deagle wasn't what you'd
call good
it was what you'd call god tier
prior to global offensive the desert
eagle held the distinction
of being the only sidearm in the game
that could one-shot headshot
through armor that meant that with the
right hand guiding it
this sluggish but stately side piece was
pretty much
a pocket off
[Music]
for some reason 1.6 eagle getting a
headshot with that against the opponent
with armor without it just felt
insanely satisfying but i would say that
it
at least feels to me in memory that the
the uh
1.6 steagle felt as methodical
um as the as the current eagle in cs go
and for the legends of 1.6 neo forest
get right
it was a staple of their game
now a core part of counter strike is the
eco round
one where you spend as little as
possible to guarantee rifles in a full
buy
in the next one and at some point
players realized the deagle
was the ultimate eco buy but the gun
rounds which were extremely important
obviously way more important
in in 1.6 it was night and day like you
either had
a gun round or you you didn't basically
and so there wasn't really
an option to have an smg buyer or you
know there's no tech nines or czeds or
anything like that that we have these
days
so the deagle was really the only uh
like solid
kind of play-making answer when you
didn't have a gun around in 1.6
good stop simple gonna win with the
deagle deal is still a pretty good
pistol in this like don't underestimate
it
i say pretty good it's very good
no matter how bleak things looked if you
had a deagle
you had a chance and that well sonic it
kind of walks in and out oh see your
double shuffle maybe
stunning from him yet again
oh that's amazing truly truly amazing
amy stand up and take a bowser if you
could just hit your shots
no round was unwinnable as he gets
around exists gets himself one for
on to wave good work from tracer back
off there but khan comes around it's now
three on two
minute up on top of the uh tower
we'll probably have a big role to play
sonic missed the love shop there's
oh and there he's oh he's team killed
but he's taken down minute as well
he's on one hp and after he's getting
insane
arcadian is exist
one hp first shot off arcadium he's so
low as well
ah no existence is gonna take absolutely
brilliant round
can you believe that he pulled that one
off and if you thought the diigo was
broken in 1.6
you should have seen it in source the
saw steagle was just ridiculously good
it was it was
it wouldn't work in today's world i
think because i think that it's just
too it would be too strong far too
strong because it was the the hitboxes
for the
the head that was like were bigger and
the gun was a bit more forgiving
in general and more consistent at
getting those those headshots long range
and so on so that this little steagle
was just ridiculous but
in addition to being a tad overpowered
the 1.6 and source deagles weren't
particularly faithful
to the real steel original a cumbersome
gun that is difficult to wield
the game graciously overlooks the
weapon's impracticality for combat use
with the weapon eventually becoming a
fast favor for use in tandem with a
primary weapon
that proved especially true in the early
days of global offensive
when valve implemented the game's most
broken deagle to date
that said cs go was still a very new
game and valve was constantly making
changes
in an effort to reinvent and modernize
their fabled franchise
they wanted to imbue this game with the
classic risk and reward of cs but
with a little more realism the problem
is that the developers just
couldn't find the sweet spot things came
to a head in january of 2013 when the
devs implemented a buff
that basically turned the deagle into
the precursor to the r8
one bullet to someone with armor at even
a reasonable range
does 80 plus damage which is extremely
overpowered
especially for a pistol at nearly any
range with bullets directed
anywhere on the body two shots will get
the frag
every time the overall reaction to this
update by the community this overall
sense of
overpowered features is felt so strongly
that european players commonly agree not
to use the pistol in scrims because it's
just that unfair
so in an effort to put the weapon in
check once and for all
valve implemented crucial changes to
counter-strike's signature sidearm
the accuracy of the deagle is really
inaccurate when you spam it
your bullets would just go way off
target in order to be accurate you have
to let it rest for one or two seconds
before firing again
this way you alleviate the kick and will
be bang on with your shots
unfortunately they didn't just nerf the
weapon they killed it
so after looking at all the stats the
big question is is the deagle still a
viable buy
i'd argue that it's not not anymore it
does a little bit more damage than its
original state
but the major recoil and low ammo count
makes it less desirable
the community was incensed they felt
they've been
robbed of something irreplaceable in
addition to being flashy and fun to use
the desert eagle was a comeback mechanic
like no other
crucial to the chemistry of
counter-strike sure the gun was
historically a little over-tuned
but it didn't matter the deagle was
undeniably
one of the most iconic and integral
weapons in cs but
eventually competitors were forced to
move on as for the up-and-comers who had
just started to cut their teeth and go
well it felt as if they would have to
make a name for themselves without the
deagle
yes
see in addition to nerfing valve buffed
a slew of other sidearms
paving the way for an era in which
practical pistols the p250
cz tec-9 and 57 ruled supreme
[Music]
i think it's so ridiculous man you don't
even have to let go
global offensive marked the first time
that other secondaries
could one-shot headshot through armor
and it took valve
way longer than it should have to
balance that out pistols were so stupid
that if used correctly
they could sometimes eclipse rifles well
if ever there was something to make
fnatic move fast i think it's probably
tech nines they seem to work even better
when you're running they have the
flashbangs they're going up short
it's an actual tec-9 train almost the
most vile thing i can imagine
aloo up in the a bomb site might get
overwhelmed here olofmeister picks up
the first kill a second kill flusher
comes in
hallows down is forrest and exists left
and this is working beautifully for
fnatic it exists
to take down crims that's trying to
fight their way back and forth is out in
the open
being flanked in the smoke seven bullets
he goes down
cronex it's in-game leader versus
in-game leader at the end
for roughly two years the deagle sat in
the doldrums
eclipsed and unused valve had
implemented some sleeper buffs but it
wasn't until about midway through 2015
that the community began to take notice
hey this is vue and today i'm going to
be trying to convince you that the
deagle is an
awesome gun and more than worth a buy in
certain scenarios
not only that but i think if used
correctly
in those scenarios it can be better than
both the 5.7
and the tec-9 and not only that but the
deagle is a
round changing gun whereas the five
seven and tek nine will get you more
consistent kills a lot of the time
however you will get kills that don't
necessarily mean that you're going to
win the round
however if again used correctly the
deagle will get you those kills where
you
immediately get that kill grab a gun and
win the round based on that
and with other pistols getting nerfed it
felt as if competitors were returning to
the deagle
with a newfound sense of reverence and
respect
it just i think there's a visceral side
that they just really nailed
and all of that that it's all the senses
coming together
that's the nice thing about it right you
feel something physical almost when you
shoot with it
and that's really hard to get across in
a video game obviously where you're not
getting any tactile feedback what you're
getting is visual
and audio except the devs have done the
visual the audio so well that you almost
feel like you're getting the physical
side of it too
to catch somebody peak on envy's side
and well that's what happens when you go
around the corner happy with juan dig
oh and another one
happy he could get another one here too
debris is like sweating bullets happy
he's gonna get the quad killing the ace
what is this but compared to its glory
days of 1.6
this was a new gun one that the old
guard wasn't especially accustomed to
it was slower less spammable and
required succinct movement to be
effective
the old eagles rewarded patience and
precision
this version necessitated them i'm gonna
level with you
it's a high skilled weapon you can try
to spray and pray
but the lord won't answer your prayers
with this bad boy
needless to say this new iteration of
the weapon wasn't for everybody
it used to be that the deagle was
something that everybody bought
but now it was for elite aimers only
if you bought one of these bad boys and
didn't hit that one
perfect shot there were consequences
he's right up on this b bomb side but
he's not spotted out
anybody and here's the first one but
he's missing it me who know
calyx actually swipes it back and that
is that
and who better to meet the challenge
than the very up-and-comers
who'd seemed fated never to wield it
mouse is going to be torn away from them
very very quickly
oh
then has just to find one more the molly
isn't going to touch him
and what on earth has just happened is
deagle is on fire and shocked is going
to walk into it as well nico is
on fire five he recovers the ak as well
and so the first real generation of
deaglers
was born newcomers who'd earn their
chops and go and pretty much only ever
knew the gun
as this high risk high-reward miracle
worker who'd seen the hole in the meta
and realized that
with help of some truly inhuman aim they
could fill it
in the pistol as well we expected to see
that aks in the third but it's not
happening just two dozen eagles here
oh my gosh what is
naturally as with the m4ak and iconic op
there were those whose skill with the
deagle really began to stand out
and one player in particular cemented
himself as arguably the deagle's
truest disciple i'm the best deagle
player in the world
i would probably have to name nico just
because of his highlight clips he's just
one of the best if not the best there
not a question he has to be nico just
because
he got so many clips with it and he's
really consistent with the deagle
and he can almost just win the round by
himself with the deal well they know
where nico is
he's got a desert eagle in hand there's
a smoke now keeping him out of the sight
though
can they pull this one off there's a kid
with biology nico
more than any of the weapons worshipers
nico became a testament to not only
how absurdly powerful the deagle's skill
ceiling had become
but how round defining it could be in
the right hands
three more cities left then it's nico he
been here because they've got big armor
and niko's putting in more damage but
what is that though four kills
that is only one more person to find
that's what the one versus one
is he really gonna ace nico there is a
reason he's called the best player in
the world
and i think we're witnessing it there
were others of course
simple coldzera twists lekro specialists
who habitually pulled off disgusting
unthinkable [ __ ] but they're taking
damage all the way and edward down at 23
hp but simple
catching taco there he's out he opened
another peak from simple two the deagle
shot
takes down a cold zero and another one
from simple up to three now for him
only trying to jump out but there's
nothing being seen at all not being full
control of this one and it's looking at
this point like it'll be a ninth round
they're trying to push for it
another one from deagle from there on
out alongside rifling and hopping
deagling took on an almost positional
significance
one of those things you just had to
learn if you hoped to be
a high level player if you wanted to be
a superstar
well that would require mastering it i
don't know if they're still doing it but
back in the day back at the beginning
what you would do is to work on your aim
was just headshot only servers with
deagle
that's all you did for hours just sit
there and headshot people with the
deagle
and that was seen as and i mean you do
that for a little bit and then you get
into a server where you can spray with
an ak
you're gonna i mean your skill goes
through the roof you really do start
hitting harder you hit different
needless to say the gun hadn't just
returned to competitive play
it was a core part of the very culture
of counter-strike
seen as pretty much the highest skill
cap weapon in cs go you couldn't
overstate the electricity
surrounding the one and only juan deeg
the one dig is one of those things you
bind on eco where you're trying to
decide
should i full save or you know what [ __ ]
it armored eagle let's go baby
to this day there's nothing like
watching a prodigy take on the
responsibility
of this unwieldy and expensive weapon
nothing like when they dish out not only
one beat down
but against every odd another one
i would say so i think it's kind of like
humiliating when he got one that by dick
when you have a now for a case so i
think uh
most of the brazilians they like to to
get that feeling when you just want to
tap someone at
someone's head and they're just feeling
like it's not bad
and i think that's the reason people
loves the dick
[Music]
because at the end of the day that's
what the deagle is
a gamble a gambit a hand cannon
that deals in hollow-pointed hail mary's
and that's exactly what makes it so
beautiful
rpk hopes to bring it back but he's just
hiding in the back of this bomb site
dodging the grenade jusw continues to
walk closer and closer
but flamie is his kryptonite again
just do that are you kidding me when all
is said and done
the d goal isn't just a handgun it's
counter-strike hype
incarnate his phone tried to reset with
the scout
angle from cold i didn't even think that
was possible i didn't think you'd be
able to see through
because it looked like snacks was ready
for him to walk in what the hell was
that from cold
get both the low hp cost them and sk as
we had on
cobblestone will win the second round
the deagle is
somehow both the best and the worst
value proposition in cs go
the only blaster where a single
millimeter can spell the difference
between a colossal waste of cash
and the kinds of clips that make the
game so exciting to begin with
the beagling go actually is an amazing
weapon just because of
how special it is even for the
professionals to be able to make plays
with it
because it does require an incredibly
huge amount of skill
and anticipation in a game sense like
you cannot afford to really miss a shot
at that level so
you have to be perfect and it's a weapon
that rewards you
if you're if you can find a way to be
perfect smoke down towards xbox makes a
bit more problematic in excess so just a
flashbang
he needs at least two kills out of his
chance in the round there's the first
not bad at all
let's go next time it isn't clear what
the future holds for this fabled firearm
whether after two decades this is the
deagle's final form
or valve our intent on experimenting
with it even more
but whatever else can be said about the
desert eagle one thing
is for certain counter-strike would be a
lot less interesting without it
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]
you